اذا تراجع الطواف الدعم السرير وعادت الى
مواقعها واخلص العاصمه نستطيع ان نجلس
معها من تبقى منهم لكي نتفاوض
حقيقي
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في حديث للجزيره رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
يقول ان القوات المسلحه مستعده للتفاوض
اذا انسحب الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم لكنه
قال انه لن يتفاوض مع حماتي مشيرا الى ان
الحسم في موقع الكنائب له مازال مؤجلا
وقائد قوه الدعم السريع يقول للجزيره ان
الهدف من عمليته العسكريه هو التخلص من
البرهان والبدء في عمليه التحول
الديمقراطي وينفي الحصول على دعم اجنبي
الى غالب او مغلوب معارك محتدمه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في محيط
القصر الرئاسي ومقر القيادات العامه وسط
الخرطوم وفي مدن سودانيه اخرى منظمه الصحه
العالميه ارتفاع عدد قتل الاشتباكات الى
330 والمصابين الى اكثر من 3000 وتدعو
طرفي القتال الى هدنه انسانيه لاجلاء
المحاصرين واغاثه المدنيين
ماساه يمنيه جديده مقتل 78 شخصا واصابه 77
في حادث تدافع كبير اثناء توزيع احد
التجار مبالغ ماليه حسبنا اعلنت وزاره
الصحه والسكان في صنعاء والمتحدث باسم
وزير الداخليه في حكومه انصار الله
الحوثيين يصف الحادث بالماساوي ويؤكد ان
الحكومه تحقق في الواقعه
قطر والسعوديه تعلنان الجمعه اول ايام عيد
الفطر المبارك في حين تعذرت رؤيه الهلال
في كل من عمان واندونيسيا وماليزيا ودول
شرق اسيا واستراليا ليكون العيد في تلك
الدول يوم السبت كل عام وانتم بخير الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]